my fantastic fennel and here are the
questions Heather what do you think of
today's climate strike climate strike
this is a huge deal it is a globe young
people are saying what the [ __ ] excuse
me and have walked out of school walked
out of their jobs from Nairobi to
Toronto to New York to LA I was very sad
that I was not able to be there in
person but I heard so many incredible
stories of young people from all walks
of life who just are very clear about
the stakes and are very clear about the
corruption and the rot at particularly
in our country that is stopping us from
doing what we need to do to ensure the
planet will be fine
it's our people that won't be fine it's
our the animals and the wildlife so
society as we know it just came so I
mean you literally have had I think the
the estimates have been you know well
over 10 million people young people
doing the biggest mass action in the
history of the globe today it's not like
Trump is gonna see it on TV and say call
the EPA I'm reversing my policies but
maybe get young people to vote more the
Trump problem trumpism goes away when
people vote the problem is people don't
vote people don't take participation
seriously and if you get him out if you
get him out marching and you tell them
you know what you can actually make
something of this by voting it's a start
that's an important part of it - Sarah
how do you suggest helping atheists
normalize religious dissent in countries
where a criticism of religion might lead
to jail or worse yeah well I mean the
first step would be something that's
obvious that we stand for religious
dissent here in the West know what's
happening
we are the way that that cartoonists and
and novelists have been treated in the
West in the past when you know we
there's the Rushdie affair that happened
and we had the the Danish cartoons and
we had Charlie Hebdo and the massacre
and Charlie Hebdo and there were too
many people and it's so shameful to even
think about it there were too many
people who were looking at those
massacres and at those dead bodies and
thinking well but what did they really
say and did they really hurt of we need
to think about not offending religious
sensibilities I mean which was an
appalling to do so the first step would
just be to not do that and stand for you
know liberal principles here yeah yeah
the Pope said it you know that they were
asking for it yeah you know which is
which we're very insulting to Muslims by
the way also it's the soft bigotry of
low expectations that you can't do this
without them exploding you know we
should expect better okay Andrew what do
you think of the British Parliament's
revolt against Boris Johnson you're a
British I am are you used to be I grew
up there I think they're playing a
dangerous game I think that the people
of the United Kingdom voted by a clear
majority a small one but a clear one
they wanted to leave the EU if the
Parliament decides they're not going to
do what the people wanted the response
is going to be wild anger a fury and of
course the empowerment of the populace
far right and what Boris Johnson is
attempting to do right now is to prevent
that happening to try and get a deal
which I understand is actually closer
than most people seem to think and if
Boris Johnson does that I think he's
going to win the election
with a landslide right now you won't
hear an American press that Boris
Johnson the Conservative Party
supporting brexit are 12 points ahead of
them closest rival in the polls it will
be a landslide for the right wing for
the same right wing in the Conservative
Party if what if forest can pull it off
so I think the parliaments risking
risking alienating a lot of people in
the United Kingdom
okay Tim do you think New York will
prosecute Trump while he's still in
office if they find he committed crimes
now yeah this is interesting now New
York is going after him the DEA they're
and Trump is suing well that stopped the
state of New York from getting always
the taxes it's is it really that hard to
get somebody freaking well actually
actually there's a precedent if the
house started impeachment proceedings
right they could act on the precedent
established in 1974 where Nixon's taxes
were turned over to the house
impeachment committee so there is a
precedent but they have to make the
decision that they're having an
impeachment inquiry it's also true that
in an impeachment inquiry they have much
stronger chance of getting this
conversation with the Ukrainian
president out there it's a much higher
standard when you're impeaching the
mother but let me tell you how you do it
one of the problems that the house has
always had with the intelligence
community is that the intelligence
oversight people are here and then the
appropriators are there if you can get
the chair of the House Appropriations
Committee to tell the DNI that the the
DNI no funding unless you give us
information you watch
you don't need an impeachment hearing
you just tell the intelligence community
but Dell isn't that an easy political
jab to say well the Democrats are
cutting off funding for our national
intelligence operation not a per se if
the issue is you don't keep us safe the
issue is bribery what about our true no
no this is what you want to honor them
if the reporting is correct this is a
bigger deal I think in the end you win
thank God we don't have a hollowed out
military anymore all right thank you
everybody I appreciate it
you